[Music]
there is often talk of the wage gap
between men and women but not about how
it compounds over
a lifetime because women make less take
more time out of their careers to care
for their children
and invest less than men even women who
successfully save for retirement can
find themselves with a million dollars
less in assets than their male
counterparts
that's something one wall street titan
is on a mission to fix
the downturn has been historically the
steepest and fastest that we've seen
sally krawcheck has some experience with
economic downturns
as the most powerful woman on wall
street she had a front row seat to the
great recession
how does the recession of 2008 differ
from today this downturn
happened so incredibly rapidly we went
from
bull market to bear market in record
literally record time the other
difference with this downturn it's a
she-session
it's impacting a session it is impacting
women unfortunately more than men
the last 107.08 was more evenly
distributed
that's because women hold a large share
of jobs
in leisure hospitality and retail
sectors that were hit hard by shutdowns
and making covet 19's impact on women
worse
are lost earnings due to the gender wage
gap
more than 10 thousand dollars per year
women make 82 cents to a man's dollar
it's
slowly getting better but to be frank
it's decades away from closing for white
women
a hundred plus years for black women and
200 plus years for latinx women
so just when you're ready to say that is
awful
and i'm so upset about that well the
gender
wealth gap wealth is how much money we
keep and that gender
wealth gap is 32 cents for a man's
dollar and just a single digit number of
pennies for black women
moving in the wrong direction krawcheck
says
closing that wealth gap will take more
than bigger paychecks
there have been two big drivers of
wealth in our country
one of which has been real estate which
people of color have been redlined
out of the other of which has been
investing and women and people of color
have been
kept out from that her solution ella
vest
the first investment platform designed
for women by women
created in 2014 the investment
platform's mission is to get more money
in the hands of women the investment gap
don't know that one it's that thing
where women aren't getting their fair
share because the investment industry
and almost
all its tools were built for men by man
we have an investing algorithm as other
digital first
investing platforms do ours is the only
one that takes into
account you're a woman you might say why
does that matter i'll tell you why
because we live longer because we earn
less
because our salaries peak sooner and we
keep less
and so therefore we keep less helping
other women
build wealth an idea that took root
early in her career
certainly the early 80s working on wall
street
sounds like it was hell
when i was there when i was junior you
know they were just trying to run me out
it wasn't even hidden
there'd be xerox copies of male
genitalia left on my desk
as a means of humiliating me
embarrassing me and trying to force me
out
still crotchet climbed becoming the cfo
of citigroup
and the head of its wealth management
division she says the reason she was
fired in 2008
was because she returned client funds
for missed sold
products ninety percent of traders on
the trading floors of wall street have
been men
98 of mutual fund dollars have been
managed by men 86 percent of financial
advisors have been men
you know though with that lack of
diversity
does anyone really think the financial
crisis of 07 and 08
would have been worse if there have been
more women and more people of color
nobody does the ellevest mission became
even more
pertinent when the metoo movement gain
momentum
recognizing the societal gender
imbalances
one of the drivers is money we've
received negative messages around money
over our whole lives that we're not good
at math or we're not
good investing those messages have been
harmful even before the pandemic the
number one source of stress for women
lack of money um the number one source
of stress the gender
money gap where women have so much less
money than men
which means that we women have had fewer
degrees of freedom
than men still conversations about money
are uncomfortable for many women
although they are more likely than men
to be living
paycheck to paycheck 61 percent
of women in a recent survey said they
would rather talk about their own
death yeah than about money
this is the shame that we as a society
have imposed on women about money
if we put that shame on them so that
they're not talking about it
then how do you know what raise to ask
for you don't
how do you know how to invest you don't
with tens of millions of people applying
for unemployment
crawcheck decided to pivot as we engaged
with our ellevest community
we what you know what should we be doing
how can we be helping and they said to
us we want more from you can you help us
earn more money at work can you help me
figure out
do i pay off the credit card debt first
or do i build an emergency fund
a new membership answers those questions
by giving access to career and financial
advisors
and rounds up extra chains from charges
into a savings account
money membership is even impactful for
women who don't have a lot of it
we worked to keep the price very
approachable
a dollar a month at the entry level this
is
the price of a portion of a latte a
month
in order to get the learning the
education the ability to save more
quickly
and eventually to invest early on small
steps krawcheck hopes
will help women gain more money and
more power i'll tell you while
money is women's number one source of
stress
the taking of action right the getting
that
credit card debt paid off the investing
right the having a plan for how you pay
off the student loan debt
the building of savings is the number
one driver of her confidence
in her future there are always actions
you can take
wherever you are that can improve where
you are financially
i tell there is nothing like getting
your business
in control and i want to just make a
mention of her
elves the program uh the membership fees
can range from about a dollar to nine
dollars a month for virtual and online
advice but personal coaching is
available at an extra cost
but you know she's really about starting
good
habits so yeah a dollar for you know
uh in the investing membership but you
know what establishing the habit of
checking you know your accounts all of
those things
make a big difference such an important
story because it is very difficult for
women to talk about
it is